- I'm Chris Cotton.
I'm here at VidCon.
I'm gonna ask some people
some hypothetical questions.
They're gonna tell me
what they woulda did.
I'm gonna tell them
what I woulda did.
This is What I Woulda Did.
- Stop.
You're too old for
this, I'm sorry.
- You say I'm too old for this?
- Yup.
- Can I speak to
your supervisor?
- I'm the supervisor.
- I guess we'll be
going somewhere else.
(hip hop music)
If you're friend disappeared,
what would you take
from his house first?
- Probably the dog, Bubba.
- Oh, you'd go get his dog?
- Yeah, 'cause I live with him.
So, it's like, I
raised it too, so.
- If my friend
disappeared, first thing
I'm getting from the house,
is I'm getting the computer,
and I'm deleting erry-thing.
'Cause that's my friend.
I know my friend.
Any of them.
What would you do if
someone gets too excited
while you're telling
them sex information?
- Like, a little like,
you could tell, like it
starts to pop?
- Excited, just oop.
- I would assume
that that person
would probably be
mortified, so I
wouldn't call attention to it.
Eyes up here.
- What I woulda did,
I would just start
talkin' about worst
case scenario penises.
- Oh.
- You know, you
know what I mean?
Like, when like, if
they have something,
and like, start
describing like, "Now with
"chlamydia, what
happens is, if you
"let it go on for 19 years."
What would you do if you
found a unicorn pony?
- How thick are the
legs of this pony?
I think I'd, if I could ride it,
but I would need to look
at the legs closely.
- Oh, you're gon' get in there,
you're gonna, if he lets
you, you know what I mean?
Or if he, she--
- Now, are you, milk it?
- What are you grabbing there?
- That's just the legs, I think.
I think I'm grabbing the legs.
- You're milking a unicorn pony.
- Do you think the
milk would be good?
- It's like Skittle milk.
Have you ever, have you
ever put Skittles in milk?
- What would you do if
you spoke in Autotune,
but rapped and sung
in a normal voice?
- I would probably
do a lot of texting.
(Chris laughs)
Or you know. (laughs)
- Do you think people would
think you're in The Matrix?
- In the Ma-, well, (laughs).
I'm tryin' to get the connection
from the voice to The Matrix.
- I don't know,
it's computer stuff.
What would you do if you
start laughing too hard
at a joke told by a non-friend?
You know, that one dude on the
side who just keep laughing
too hard, like?
- Yeah.
- Oh, you gotta
start roasting him.
- Yeah yeah, yeah yeah.
- Whatchu laughin' at?
- You gotta have this
hand, right here.
- I gotta?
- Yeah it's
- Whatchu laughin' at?
- It's fired down.
It's what--
- You do?
We always say,
"(beep) outta here,"
and then you come up.
I don't know you.
But them sneaks, though.
And then you go away.
- So you're establishing.
- I'm already hurt.
- You're establishing
territory, you gotta,
no, I get it.
- Oh, yeah.
You gotta flare up, you
gotta chest out on 'em.
- Chest out, arm up.
- You're a compound roaster.
- What would you do
if in your videos,
you couldn't add
a dramatic noise?
(dramatic horns)
What do you do if
the government gave
black people reparations,
but it was literally,
three acres and a mule?
- Well I would build a house.
- [Chris] You would build
a house on your acres.
- I would start my own compound,
and I would start preparing
for the end of the world.
- Okay, because you know if they
gave back the
reparations, things--
- Things are already
down the drain.
Like, it's already, we're
already going there.
- The Space Force
done launched, baby.
- Yeah.
- Listen, in this video,
we're gonna find one gem.
It's all edited.
They call me,
fix-it-in-post Chris.